على قارعه الطريق ينتظر رزقه
في جنوب شرقي الخرطوم انتهى مدخره من نقود
لكن عليه طعام اسرته حاله كحال كثير من
اصحاب المواصلات العامه الذين استغلوا
الهدى والهدوء النسبي في مناطقهم للعمل
ونقل الركاب بين الاحياء والمناطق الاقل
خطوره في العاصمه
[موسيقى]
اربع اولاد ومستاجر وشغال رزق اليوم ما
عنده حلل الا اطلع اشتغل
ونتمنى ربنا يصلح الحال ان شاء الله ويهدي
البال ان شاء الله
حركه المواصلات في عدد من الاحياء بجنوب
العاصمه عادت جزئيا لكنها تخضع لخطوط سير
تتجنب المناطق الملتهبه عوده مكنت عدد من
سكان هذه المناطق من الحركه لقضايا
اشغالهم او الالتحاق باهلهم في مناطق اخرى
اسعد من امس جاي المواصلات الراي شغاله
بنمشي لحد دريم ومن دريم باجي هنا لحد
الستين
تمشي 13 وتمشي الحاج يوسف وكلها شغاله
يعني ما في ما وقفت منا الصباح هايسات على
عربات كبيره
الاقفال الذي طال اغلبيه محطات الوقود في
جنوب العاصمه بسبب الوضع الامني المضطرب
فتح سوقا موازيه لبيع الوقود على الطرقات
وباسعار مرتفعه لكن الاسعار عادت فتدنت
قليلا مقارنه باول ايام المواجهات المسلحه
فسعر جالون البنزين انخفض من اربعين الف
جنيه سوداني الى 25 الف وهو ما يعادل
بالدولار الامريكي 80 دولار الى 50 دولارا
للجالون توافر الوقود ولو في السوق
الموازيه ينظر اليه كثير من سكان هذه
المناطق على انهم انفراجا تسهل حركتهم
وتنقلهم وقد تتوفر السلع وتنخفض اسعارها
اذا استمر الوضع على ما هو عليه العوده
الجزئيه لمواصلات الداخليه في عدد من
المناطق التي لم تشهد مواجهات مسلحه في
جنوب العاصمه خلال الايام الماضيه تعد
مؤشرا لمحاولات قاطني هذه المناطق للتعايش
مع ظروف مضطربه لا يعلمون متى والى اين
ستنتهي مالاتها وعمر الطيب الجزيره جنوب
شرقيه الخرطوم